Aloha rejects its Greg here John here so
we got a sent this this is a video that
is from February 15 2012
it's a sci-fi horror short film boo that
in the past four years it accumulated
over 5 million views
damn now Andrea Rika Rita not sure to
say it she directed this search from her
channel to let's see what this all down
I'm excited I didn't know this was gonna
be sure
Oh God
Wow
interesting
[Music]
that real spider smart go put a top on
it speck trust and sleep here not under
the sheets my jeans and shoes off
[Music]
Oh No
[Music]
ha
Oh gross
that would be the most [ __ ]
horrifying thing that would be so
terrifying dude
[Music]
[Music]
this injury is husband or something
oh my god it's already producing others
[Music]
why don't watch
[Music]
very calm terrifying situation
I get all resident evil man nice this
guy do for a living
No
[Music]
yeah oh dude you're dead
ah yeah there's no way out of this man
come on you though okay this guy's
constantly calling about what the
situation is
[Music]
it's like a basketball
[Music]
that spiders father was like a beach
ball a Nickelback concert
[Music]
although you did it
I'm just glad he's okay
and I mean look how exhausted he looks
[Music]
ah oh no no don't grab that roll
[Music]
that was fun that was a lot of fun that
was a lot of very much fun I very much
enjoyed that I usually get a little
nervous when I do like a reaction
especially yeah the review part now we
get nervous about but the reaction part
I don't want anything to like
miscommunicate yeah because even though
I'm laughing I feel like some of this or
a lot of it was probably intentional it
has to be yeah yeah not me because I
first thought I get worried since I says
I know sometimes people intend to make
something really cool and great and then
you find yourself laughing a lot of it
and you're like maybe that's just kind
of disrespectful to the filmmaker to do
that but something tells me like this
seems like I'm it's kind of put your
b-movie homage style oh yeah yeah crazy
giant spiders and stuff and like the way
it was all executed I thought was really
fun
yeah tribute to 50 science fiction likes
right no this was the a nursery the
description yeah cuz everything kind of
kind of matches the CGI spiders and
stuff like that you know it helps to
make those come more to life - you know
embracing that b-movie vibe yeah
everything works
I'm not sure what this actor was doing
like so nonchalant in the most
high-stakes situations guys just captain
calm and calm guy when he eats a button
he kills a bunch of spiders takes on the
biggest one who doesn't notice it I'm
like a [ __ ] Apple or whatever he
played a lot of fighter shaped food jobs
done it's love his journey of it is like
a spider I'm gonna lay on my bed now
keep my shoes in jeans oh oh
waking up spiders not there nice open
cage there's a big spider better walk
away from the big spider now there's
more spiders go outside let's take on
the next button
my
I want to sell this enjoyable inchers
spider danger that was really [ __ ]
funny I really like that and like thank
you for making that and yeah I like the
spider a BEC seem like cheesy and corny
but fashionable I think it's still
disgusting when he eats the spider yeah
yeah like oh no matter how no matter how
much you can tell where the effects are
just the idea is so yes settings as you
can imagine it there are big enough
spiders that you can imagine what one
that size might be like and that's [ __ ]
yeah that was a fun time and it's like
it's obvious of this that andreas really
likes you know she and she seems like
someone who was drawn to like old-school
visual effects and wanted to pay homage
that and pay tribute to that it's very
present here in this vibe so I'm not
expecting like the most state-of-the-art
technology yeah exactly
I'm sure this was made with like no
money that's what it has a subscription
really should read the description
before so yeah zero budget it just cook
something up like what's the company
called dream dream movies up or dream
them up or something I kind of took it
was as I cook them up kind of like short
film you know with some visual effects
that was fun I like how its put together
enough that I like I would definitely
like to see more and what you can do
when you actually have a little money
yeah
all right rejects go if you want to
watch the original video as a link in
the description box spider danger and
dried Rika has her own channel and you
can subscribe to us the real rejects and
John his reasons Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram and he is also the social
media manager of Facebook's bloom house
and and what's the other one the real
rejects we're on right now